hello and welcome to the debate on Sky
News I'm Neil Patterson here's our take
on developments brought together from
America the UK and around the world the
global terror threat the increasing
power of Isis Ebola has no killed eight
thousand people what's being done to
stop the spread and should the United
Nations be more proactive in 2015 will
be speaking to the deputy
secretary-general Ebola Syria Isis
refugees Ezreal Palestine it's a list
that could go on indefinitely and it's
the 2015 to-do list for the United
Nations as it approaches its 70th
anniversary well in just a moment Yan
Ellison the UN's deputy
secretary-general will be in the studio
but first as usual let's hear from the
Democrat commentator Geoffrey Robinson
in New York and the conservative
commentator Armstrong Williams joining
us from Washington at Jeffrey let's
start with you if we can there can
hardly be a un secretary-general indeed
who wouldn't concede that at times the
fortunes of the United Nations have been
a little bit scattered but it does truly
remain a force for good in the 21st
century it certainly remains a force for
Hope in the 20th first century it does a
number of things very very well that
never make any headlines of things like
legislation for maritime law space law
cleaning up the oceans with pollution of
United Nations International Children's
Fund UNICEF the World Health
Organization a lot of it is wonderful
the headlines unfortunately tend to show
the slip ups and where the UN fails and
where the UN bogs down and I don't think
they're necessarily fair but it's a
reality of the UN that most people think
of it as a committee that's drawing a
horse and comes up with a camel you know
that old expression that it's just too
big too bulky to confused and doesn't
really work well I'm still moving on
from Jeffrey's point given just how
often these days we are seeing you know
individual states
operating on their own outside the UN
dream it or even in kind of ad hoc
coalition's maybe what is the role for a
supranational organization like the
United Nations these days you know what
Jeffrey said you cannot really argue
with but you know the United States
Nations if you think about the main
purpose is to resolve issues between
countries through diplomacy before these
countries resort to military force and
before conflicts escalate and so the
problem unfortunately if you look at the
entire history of the United Nation it
has consistently failed us goal and will
continue being unless and they're
factors that have caused this through
really no fun at all it's just how
they're organized the United Nations is
primarily a forum for debate I mean it
as a result it is an international
organizations where countries send
representatives to argue for against
issues and the other thing that you just
mentioned about many of these countries
are the United Nations in the first
place they're just not for peace these
nations have very questionable voting
practices and the only possible solution
and I know Jeffrey's going to think that
this is radical is the divided sort of
denied voting rights for non
peace-loving nations and this includes
any non free and not democratic country
who would be biased towards dictators
and regimes and so I just think the
united nations especially when you have
five nations that can veto any
resolution that the majority of the
United Nations members agree upon
there's the structure the way is
organizing set up they cannot work and
they cannot be a force of a good when it
comes to these kinds of issues something
has to change well let's now speak with
the deputy general secretary of the
United of the United Nations at yan
Elias and in a New York studios for us
today good afternoon to you mr. Ellison
let's let's start with one of those
topics on which the United Nations
perhaps might have been made more
progress and indeed one of those issues
which really is a top of the agenda for
individual governments that of that of
global terror what is the United Nations
role in combating the rise of
organizations at such as Isis
well I think we all have an obligation
to work do everything we can to stop
this plague of terrorism it has to do
with their dealing with the acute
situations like ISIL in Iraq and Boko
Haram in cooperation with the government
concerned but also we need to look at
the deeper causes of these phenomena and
that's why we should recall the United
Nations is not only responsible for
working for peace and security but also
for development respect of Human Rights
so I think what we need to look at in
today's world is to see the power or
working at the same time with issues
related to peace development in human
rights and this requires action from us
and the United Nations but also for
member states and other stakeholders in
the international system there are
clearly overarching aims long-term goals
for the United Nations but at times it
does feel as if the UN can't act as
quickly as it might let's take for
example Syria where Isis now has a has a
more than just a foothold the United
Nations Mission left there in 2012 and
arguably the situation hasn't improved
since then you're right of course we
should remind ourselves that the
chemical weapons were destroyed and
destructed to taken away with the action
through the United Nations but I regret
very deeply that we don't have a strong
enough security council resolution for
our work in the Syria both Kofi Annan
and de lucht abra he me great
negotiators came to the conclusion that
they didn't have enough muscle through
the job so what we are have to do is
deal with a very very serious
humanitarian situation which is just
enormously
damaging to the countries in the region
I just came back from Lebanon 1.5
million refugees in the population of
4.5 every third inhabitant in Lebanon is
a refugee and we are there and try to
save lives both inside Syria and in the
region it is at times difficult to see
that the IT nations is making much
progress in terms of its primary primary
objective at the idea that it is to
combat the scourge of war but this year
for example we have seen record numbers
of peacekeepers 130,000 of them on the
ground tackling problems which other
governments wish not to wish not to
involve themselves with yeah that's the
thing well I would like to ask mr.
Ellison something that it directly
concerns this we see a public face of
the United Nations in the Security
Council and the General Assembly and
it's televised and and resolutions come
up nations signed them and then ignore
them basically ignore them and there's
time and time again I mean I can cite a
dozen cases where things have simply
been ratified and then completely
ignored at home but I'm interested in
the whole idea of backchat you've got
the building on the on the East River
and every diplomat there has access to
every other diplomat there mr. Ellis and
how much backchat goes on private
meetings between players who might not
necessarily want to be seen in public
how much of that happens and has any of
it ever proved useful well a lot of such
contexts it takes place I have been
working in many years in the UN and I
would say the discussions the corridors
the informal contacts United Nations as
a meeting place is a function which is
not sufficiently known and sufficiently
used but and and understood I think we
should also remember that we can conduct
quiet diplomacy and try to reach
solutions without headlines and under
the radar understandably I cannot now
describe such situations but I can tell
you that every day we have some type of
contact of this nature under the rain
our discrete channels talking to key
actors in conflict areas to try to
reduce the level of violence and above
all to prevent crises we have instituted
now a system of them looking at human
rights violations as the first sign of
possible method mass atrocities so we
now have something we call human rights
up front where we act on the early
stages of human rights violations rather
than waiting for mass atrocities that
requires also a number of quiet contacts
in the situations which are of this
nature so I'm glad you pointed to this I
think we should not forget that
Armstrong there is perhaps an
understandable focus on the fact that
the the Security Council is sometimes
stymied by that veto possessed by the at
the five permanent members but as mr.
Ellison was was was elaborating on there
it is what happens elsewhere within the
United Nations in the margins in those
back rooms the discussions that take
place that simply doesn't happen
anywhere else in the world there is no
other organization that could that
facilitate those discussions but listen
in all fairness these countries help
this power because they were the
founding members of the United Nations
that they wrote the rules of the UN at
the World War two but unfortunately this
non democracy fails for several reasons
first only a true democracy among
nations is unbiased in fair and does the
complete structure of this organization
needs a major overhaul and this too is
not likely to happen since the countries
with Vito and power are unlikely to
unanimously agree and you can understand
to give up the right for fairness sake
but I want to mention something to the
audible gasp and that is when you talk
to him about this issue of terrorism you
know I get into this in mind in mind
when we talked initially about why the
United Nations continues to be a failure
in many ways is because it's useless and
I emphasize the word useless when it
comes to terrorism the United Nations
does not even formally recognize any
country as a terrorist state not not
even recognizing them and furthermore
terrace I
not interested in the politics of
debating and a public forum such as the
United Nations we listen to discuss and
work out their issues and so what
happens United Nations does not get
involved in politics with terrorist
groups and as a result it is completely
blinded to terrorist groups has no plans
to address terrorism and has no
intentions of changing and so when you
ask them that question the fact is is
that the United States as the largest
international organization that promotes
peace is completely unable and no
offense mr. deputy you're unable to
address terrorism because it is further
proof that you're ineffective because
you don't even recognize these blood is
terrorists as terrorist States so how do
you how can you even begin to help
resolve these issues if you can't even
acknowledge that terrorism exists in
these states well I think that is a bit
exaggerator because we certainly have a
counterterrorism strategy adopted by the
General Assembly and the Security
Council has a committee which deals with
terrorism and we have sanctions against
terrorist groups and we are of course
fully implementing this and we work with
member states I can't say that we are
working I just came back from Iraq I
came back from Nigeria I am been talking
with my colleagues about the Boko Haram
and ISIL and we are working on a
strategy on how to diminish their own
how to expand the credibility of the
government in the case of Iraq for
instance so that the different soon I
groups stand behind the government
rather than supporting ISIL in the north
we are doing work on this all the time
you we I can't work with the Syria or
Iraq situation we are without dealing
with terrorism mr. Ellison let's move on
to a topic on which the UN has latterly
made some progress Ebola the outbreak in
West Africa which is led to the death of
some 8,000 people what is your appraisal
of the way in which the United Nations
has reacted and subsequently developed
its response to Ebola there is a huge
effort going on and we are mobilizing
the whole UN system we are getting
tremendous help from countries ranging
from the United States to China to Q
to the African countries we are seeing
difference on the ground particularly in
Liberia we have seeing more problems in
Sierra Leone and Guinea yeah but I think
we are moving the right direction we of
course have learned one thing already
and that goes for not only health crisis
but also for humanitarian crisis and for
development crisis and that is we have
to act as early as possible the sooner
you get into a problem area in all these
areas the better we are doing our
absolutely best and we promised the
people of Liberia Sierra Leone and
Guinea that we will be on their side not
only at this stage but also in the
recovery stage we live we are talking
about countries who have very very poor
systems of the healthcare and we need to
help them be more better prepared for
such pandemics in the future this some
people might be surprised by the fact
that this was the first ever UN
emergency health mission I mean is there
no an argument that there should be a
health equivalent of of the peacekeeping
mission which is proved successful in
other parts of the world I see Geoffrey
nodding his head there but at a deputy
secretary response first well I think
you are absolutely right and we we are
working right now and wh 0 and others on
a emergency response facility at a
possibility to act immediately and we
hope that the wh 0 will will will will
go in that direction we definitely have
to have an equivalent of what we have in
the humanitarian response an area which
I worked with very much myself where we
almost have automatic reactions in
situations at the earliest ages and this
is certainly the realization of the
leadership of wh 0 but also the
leadership of the United Nations so we
hope that we will have the supporter
member states to have such a facility
and that is one of the lessons learned
from the Ebola crisis Geoffrey why is it
mr. Ellison why is it taking so long
disasters and crises are nothing new to
the United Nations whether it be refugee
crises or earthquakes like Haiti
or Ebola or any number of things that
have happened in the last 70 years why
doesn't the United Nations establish a
peacekeeping disaster force that can
bring in medicine that can bring in
doctors that can bring in relief workers
that can really react immediately what
would it take to institute such a force
I think we are in the way of creating a
facility of a similar nature but you
should not forget that we should also
have a better facility better
possibilities for the countries
themselves to act early on to always
think that it is someone come flying in
from the outside to solve the problems
is sometimes necessary when you have
situations where things are getting out
of the control but I think what we need
to know is that we have that
preparedness together with the countries
that are less privileged you know the
the able are we if it were had to strike
business tracking a United States or
Europe we will probably have a mortality
rate or twenty twenty-five percent but
in these three countries you have had
sixty to seventy five percent mortality
mainly reflecting the fact that we have
such poor health systems so we have to
do a combination of of having massive
reactions when needed in crazy
situations but also understand that we
have to build up national capacity
Armstrong the the w wh 0 the World
Health Organization might have been
better placed to respond to the bowler
crisis if the United States and others
hadn't cut their funding to the wh 0
well the United States cuts is funding
because the you know the United Nations
is not necessarily a popular
organization in the United States and
not only just resistance against its
everyday citizens but also members of
Congress and who are in very powerful
positions who control those purse
strings but I don't want to just totally
not recognize the and embrace the Deputy
Secretary General on something he said
with the issue of Ebola because the UN
mission for bowlin emergency response is
the first-ever UN emergency health
mission
and while we may talk about that others
could have stepped in the into a very
good job with these safe and dignified
dignified barriers that they do a very
good job with the social mobilization
the managing these cases finding
contacts and tracing people and
sometimes you know that human touch is
important while you may not have saved
as many people as you want to say the UN
does a very good job with the human
touch with the compassion and making
people feel that and believe that they
care and showing them how they can
empower themselves and help them better
organized because they go into some
citrus situations that we don't even
have the capability of the capacitor
really I realized that people can live
in these kind of conditions so I I think
kudos really go to the United Nations
when it comes to their health response
and what they were able to put in place
it can always be better but I think it's
also important to recognize when they
also do a good job a job that could not
be done if they were not there and many
people would suffer even more if their
presence was not felt in that region
well I'm glad that you pointed to what
we do out there in the field I am
basically a field person I was
responsible humanitarian affairs in the
world earlier and now I go out to all
these crisis areas and I see my
colleagues I'll see them working under
tremendously difficult circumstances we
have lost hundreds and hundreds of
peacekeepers of humanitarian workers of
health personnel in our missions the
world is getting more and more dangerous
United Nations isn't always seen as a
neutral force we are sometimes taking
stand against terrorists I prefer what
we just discussed and I just want always
to record particularly to the American
public which reflected reflecting this
skepticism just talked about haven't
seen what we do out there on the field
we have in today's world over 50 million
people refugees or displaced people and
we are taking para practicar of
practically all of them not not as much
as well as we should because we have
problems with funding and we are out
there to vaccinate children we are there
to give education and we do so much out
there in the field I wish that the
skeptics of the UN would see the work
out
the field and to see the sacrifices that
we are making true to do that and we
always try to put in front of us every
day the three first words of the Charter
we the peeples it is to the people's we
want to deliver peace development in
human rights and I'm I'm grateful you
that you brought up this field
perspective mr. Ellison isn't perhaps
part of the problem that the United
Nations itself although it has expanded
you know we have a number of autonomous
agencies now we have a number of funds
numerous other connected organizations
that actually at its core the United
Nations hasn't since its inception
changed structurally despite the fact
that compared to where we started in
terms of member states will over three
times as large well the UN Charter is a
still a beautiful document and the
organization is basically a fully
democratic organization one nation one
vote except of course in the Security
Council where you have five nations who
have the veto right and that was the
insurance at the time of the creation of
the United Nations that the major powers
would take the United Nations seriously
it was a bit of a sacrifice for to
maintain that function and I would hope
that those who have those veto powers
would use it with with responsibility in
other words as as as seldom as possible
because they have an obligation to stand
up for international peace and security
I think we need to reform and I think
the most important direction we have to
go up rapport the earlier discussion
that is to act early we have to act
early at the first vibration of a
conflict we have to act early when we
see a disease appearing when we see the
human rights area children can't go to
school because of their their ethnic
background or religious grouping then we
have to get in there and I think if we
move this spectrum this attention to the
early part of the conflicts early part
of of negative developments then we have
made a quality step forward and then we
must understand United Nations will be
as strong as the member says want it to
be and I think that we should understand
the united nations cannot do it
alone we need the help of governments we
need the help of civil society we need
the help of the academic institutions we
need the help of individuals if we
really work through the United Nations
and and realize that this work is in our
national interest then I think we can
achieve a bit substr it goes on step
forward this crucial year we will this
year both have a decision on the
sustainable development goals for the
next 15 years and we will have a
decision in Paris on the climate change
measures these are historic measures and
i hope the member states now feel
solidarity with the people and look put
their situation in the front and come to
good conclusions of these two major
negotiations Armstrong that there can't
be many people who look at the job of
secretary-general with envy I mean as
mr. Ellison was alluding to there it is
essentially a huge job but with you know
close to 200 bosses are we at the point
now saying that we need to bring in a
secretary general from outside the
system you know the likes of a Tony
Blair style figure with real quite or
dead I even said a President Obama you
know sometimes I think will we bring in
these former heads of states I noticed
the even former Secretary of State
Hillary Clinton was touted as someone
that could hear an organization a
similarity but you bring these people in
because they were heads of states and
they've run countries sometimes you need
people who have really been in the
trenches who've been on the ground who
spent years and decades understanding
exactly what is needed exactly what
needs to change and where you could be
most effective and sometimes you want to
bring in these high power figures
because it brings in money it brings in
Perl is publicity brings in stature but
it doesn't necessarily empower and make
the difference in the lives of the
people where they are and I think what
the Deputy Secretary General is saying
about what they do in the field and it
is true that many UN forces are
considered as terraces and not friendly
and they put their lives on the line
some of them died from Ebola some of
them died in the most crazy and
unimaginative situations and I think
what you need is leadership that not
that works not cosmetic not someone that
we all recognized as a world figure but
somebody that people recognize that
get their hands dirty you can go on and
get the job done sometimes you need just
an ever there personally take that
position and move this organization
forward mr. Ellis a final question to
you in this the the year of the UN's
70th anniversary and is it's the UN's
greatest achievement that they can say
look the world's would have been far
worse without us indeed can the UN
actually ever hope to achieve any more
than that I think the world would have
been in much worse shape without the
United Nations not only are we setting
the norms and the values and the
principles that we would like to see
guide the world principles that we need
to be reminded of in today's world every
minute every minute because the horrors
are there in war and atrocities and
violations human rights and extreme
poverty and inequalities so we stand for
the world that we want to see and then
the second question is how much do we
want to use this tool how much want to
use this machinery and then we must
understand that if we do that we
actually serve our own nation's interest
maybe 15 20 30 40 years ago that wasn't
the case you could say the national
interest is there and the International
is there but in today's where they come
together you cannot divide up home and
outside it's coming together you see it
all over the world the word exists
inside our countries and we exist in the
world and of course we need to do better
and we must do acting early acting early
this I think as I come back again is the
main thing to do to remember and the
United Nations is there to serve and I
just say if we can just have more of
political will helping us move forward I
think we can improve conditions in the
world and we need to do so deputy
secretary general young Ellis and thanks
very much your time and as always
Jeffrey and Armstrong courtesy well
that's it for this edition of the
debates until next time goodbye